okay so i guess uh let's uh get started
with with part two oh pulling uh some of
the audience were asking if you'd be
willing to make your notes available
sure yeah okay thank you
all right so let's get started
okay great um so the next
lecture will be about robustness
so here's the reference
by chen
gao and run
a general decision theory
for
huber's
epsilon contamination model
in 2016. um so we'll be focusing on um
on lower bounds when we have some form
of robustness of our estimators
so here's a little bit of background on
hoover's epsilon contamination model
so this was the this is the most
classical form of contamination model in
robust statistics
so we suppose that we have iid
observations
from 1 minus epsilon p
plus epsilon q
and the goal
is to estimate
theta of p
where q is an arbitrary contaminating
distribution
okay so we'll define a minimax risk
so the minimax
risk is going to be
r sub let's say uber
of script p the loss function l and the
level of contamination
and this is the infimum over theta hat
supremum over
the true distribution as well as the
contaminating distribution
expectation where x is coming from
one minus epsilon p plus epsilon q
and now we have niid observations
l of
theta hat of x
theta of p
so just remember that we always have i d
observations it's a little bit awkward
to keep writing this unfold product but
i wanted to keep the notation consistent
with the last lecture
so as before
we assume that
the loss function l is of the form v
composed with rho
okay so
here's a definition it's a lower bounds
or in terms of this notion of modulus of
continuity
so the modulus
of continuity
this is a notion that comes from donahoe
and liu
1991
is defined by omega of epsilon
p
is
equal to the supremum
rho of theta of p1 theta of p2
such that total variation distance
between
p1 and p2 is bounded by epsilon over 1
minus epsilon and p1 and p2
is in script p
okay so um this
well the the result that i'll state in a
moment tells us that
the the minimax risk so the hardness of
this problem um involves this quantity
omega and just to give you an idea of
why this makes sense um so what we want
to know is is how hard is it to
distinguish um two distributions right
so we're measuring everything everything
in terms of the loss l which is really
kind of some version of rho
rho tells us how far away the thetas
look um when the two distributions are
close and closeness is measured in total
variation
um sense and and this uh i'll mention a
little bit at the very end about how you
could think about other distances
instead um the reason why we look at the
total variation senses is very related
to the fact that we are in hoover's
epsilon contamination model um
so uh i guess let me write this down so
you can think about
um this
this quantity here as the uber epsilon
ball
now hoover isn't really a distance but
um you can think about these
distributions as anything that's kind of
within this hubert distance
um and it turns out that any of these
contaminating contaminated distributions
also lie inside the total variation
epsilon ball
and that's why we see a total variation
coming up here
okay
so um
with this definition
we have the following main result
the theorem is that
for any level of contamination between
epsilon between zero and one
the min and max risk
satisfies the bound r sub uber
script p
l epsilon is bigger than or equal to the
max
of r sub over
p
l of zero
and
one half v of
the modulus of continuity over two
okay um so one other thing i wanted to
say was let's go back to this definition
of minimax risk um so for the the third
and fourth lectures um i'll be talking
about minimax risk where the estimator
itself is constrained to being something
whether it's differentially private or
or computable in polynomial time etc
this problem this characterization is a
little bit different because here we're
still looking at all estimators
but we've changed the
notion of risk a little bit so now we're
allowing our x's to come not from just
the clean distribution but some
contaminated distribution so in some
sense this is not really a robustness
constrained estimator we're not
requiring theta hat to be robust but
this is saying that we want an estimator
to perform well even when the data
actually happened to come from some
perturbation and maybe for those of you
who work on adversarial risk in the
modern machine learning sense this will
be quite familiar to you
so you want an estimator that performs
well even when data are contaminated
therefore you would ask what's the best
possible estimator i could get um under
this sliding distribution
okay so going back to our theorem um so
our theorem says that we want to look at
this huber risk then we can take the max
of two quantities
and really the first quantity is sort of
trivial so let's go through the proof of
this
okay so um so the first remark
is that
the fact that
r uber
p l epsilon is greater than or equal to
r
over
p l zero is trivial so this is just
um the usual risk this is the non-robust
or i'll just say usual minimax risk
all right because all we're doing here
is we're saying well um it's as if we we
didn't add any contamination at all so q
is just the same as p
okay so there's really just one thing to
prove and that is
this
that this second
bound holds
um
okay so we will focus
on improving the second
lower bound
okay
so consider a pair
e1 p2
which solves
program
supremum over
rho of theta p1
theta p2
such that the tdp distance between p1
and p2 is less than or equal to epsilon
over one minus epsilon okay so this is
really just saying um if we go back to
the definition of modulus of continuity
consider a pair that maximizes um this
uh this row which corresponds to the
solution of modulus of continuity
um
so maybe i'll write this as a little
lemma because it's kind of a side result
um
so lemma is that the hoover epsilon
balls
around p1 and p2 intersect
um
so
there
exists um
uh maybe i'll say that
uh 1 minus epsilon times p1 plus epsilon
times q1
equals p prime equals 1 minus epsilon p2
plus epsilon q2
for some
q1 and q2
okay
and let me quickly jot down what this
proof is
[Music]
you can check for yourself that this
construction works
so
we will construct the distribution
so we will
construct
q1 and q2
to make what's called a star hold
okay so
um
uh well so there exists epsilon prime
less than or equal to epsilon such that
rho of theta p1
theta of p2 equals omega of epsilon
script p
and total variation distance between p1
and p2 is equal to epsilon prime over
one minus epsilon prime okay so these
guys maximize um this program and that
means that we have to actually achieve
what the modulus of continuity is
however the tv distance might be smaller
than epsilon over 1 minus epsilon so
there's some epsilon prime for which we
have equality there
so now
define
the density functions
p1 equals dp1 over
dp1 plus dp2 and p2 is
dp2 over
dp1 plus dp2 so this is just a rescaling
of the densities
[Music]
and then define q1
and q2
by the density functions
dq1 over
dp1 plus
dp2 is equal to little p2
minus p1
as an indicator that p2 is bigger than
equal to p1
divided by the total variation distance
between p1 and p2
and dq2 is defined similarly
dp1 plus dp2 is equal to p1 minus p2
indicator that
p1 it's bigger than or equal to p2
divided by the total variation
okay so um so you can check
that dq1
and dq2
integrate
to 1
and star holds
okay so i'm not going to go through the
details of verifying this computation
but maybe just to draw a picture so um
imagine that you have p1 and p2
let's say this one is p1 and this one is
p2
okay so you want to construct somebody
who's in the epsilon
in the huber ball so you think about
shrinking down these densities by one
minus epsilon
and then adding something else to them
maybe i should have different colors
well okay fine so we we shrink them down
and then we have to add something else
to each of these distributions and then
we get um
we get this distribution which is a
shrunk version of p1 plus something else
and the shrunk version of youtube was
something else so the something else's
that we add depend on whether
p2 is bigger than p1 or p1 is bigger
than p2 so if we're thinking about what
to add to the distribution of p1 then we
add things only on the set where p2 is
bigger than p1 so we sort of shrink it
down we add things here and then for the
other guy we also shrink it down we add
things here and things work out so that
um and so that the expressions are
exactly what we should be adding on okay
but i won't dwell on that um so what's
the point so
we have these two distributions uh p1
and p2 and we know that the uber balls
intersect now we're going to play around
with this statement okay
so
um
let delta be bigger than zero
that's the end of that proof
um
then so now we go back to our minimax
risk quantity supremum p in script p
and over all contaminations q
probability that x is distributed as one
minus epsilon p
plus epsilon q to the n
um and we're interested in the quantity
um
where this guy is
rho of theta hat of x
theta of p
is bigger than or equal to delta okay
so we're really interested in the loss
function l
but later we're going to
later we're going to to put a fee
function there to make it equal to l
okay so let's play with with this um
with this guy here and this is equal
this is greater than bigger than or
equal to one half well
over q so here we're going to take an
average of two possible values of p and
which values of p will be choosing of
course they'll choose p1 and p2 because
that's just what we were dealing with a
moment ago
so soup over q
of probability x is coming from
1 minus epsilon p1
plus epsilon q to the n
rho of theta hat of x
theta of p1
bigger than or equal to delta
plus one half soup over q
probability of x coming from 1 minus
epsilon p2 plus epsilon q to the n
rho of theta hat of x theta of p2 is
again equal to delta okay so we've used
this trick where
of course the soup is bigger than or
equal to the average of any of the
points that lie in the set
um
and in particular we know that a
particular instantiation of a
contamination distribution is what we
call p prime that common distribution
that lay in both sets
so this is bigger than or equal to one
half of
oops
oops
this is one half of
the probability that x is coming from p
prime
rho of theta hat of x
theta of p1 bigger than or equal to
delta
plus one half probability that x is
coming from again p prime because p
prime lived inside the second
contamination ball as well
um
rho of theta hat of x
theta of
p2 bigger than or equal to delta
here
okay
um so now we're going to take
delta to be a particular value let's
call it one half of the modulus of
continuity
um
then by the triangle inequality
the right hand side is further lower
bounded by one half probability x coming
from p prime
rho of theta hat of x theta of p2 oops
that's not what i meant i meant theta
hat of n theta of p1 theta of p2
bigger than or equal to two delta
right and this is because um
well certainly if
if the distance because rho satisfies
the triangle inequality so certainly if
the distance between t1 and p2 in theta
sense at least two delta then at least
one of them has to be bigger than
delta
okay but now remember that we actually
chose um p1 and p2 to be um two delta
separated
uh
sorry well that's not okay so what did
we do um
i'm getting i don't want to confuse you
because we're not in founders inequality
anymore at the moment so what did we
choose about p1 and p2 we actually chose
these two guys so that this was an
equality right so we chose
so because um delta is one half of the
modulus of continuity we want to ask
well
um
maybe i'll write this here so this is
um
this is equal to
uh one half probability x is coming from
p delta p p prime to the n
rho of theta p one theta p two is bigger
than or equal to omega of
epsilon rho right this is by our choice
of um
epsilon p this is by our choice of uh
of delta
right by your choice of delta and in
fact we chose p1 and p2 to be two
distributions that achieved the modulus
of continuity in the supremum
right so we said consider p1 and p2
which optimizes this definition
therefore in fact this is equal to
modulus of continuity so we see that
there's no probability here and this is
always equal to one-half times one or
one-half
okay
so here what what have we done we've
gotten a bound of one-half on
this probability and of course we want a
risk so we relate the risk to the
probability using markov's inequality
so
therefore
by markov
we have expectation under
x distributed as
1 minus epsilon
p plus epsilon q
to the n
of
l of theta hat x theta of p
so the real risk will have a bunch of
supremums on the left side but let's not
write them for now this is bigger than
or equal to
so markov's inequality i can put in
whatever i want and i'll put in this guy
times probability that
l of
theta hat
of x theta of p
is at least
phi of omega epsilon p over two right
and i'm not going to write down what the
probabilities take with respect to but
it's the same thing
um
and this is equal to so here's where i
remind myself that
l is equal to v composed with rho
so this is phi of omega epsilon p over 2
times probability that rho of theta hat
theta of p
is at least omega of
epsilon p over 2.
right and
this is
exactly what i have calculated
back up over here so here um
delta was
was omega over 2 right so um
so this is um this is going to be
greater than or equal to one-half times
um
times phi of
omega of
uh
actually i think i i probably need to
take a soup first so
taking
soup
over p and q
on both
sides and using
the inequality above
so that was this inequality here right
so
we need to take a soup first because we
have a soup of these guys
um
we get
the minimax risk
r of h uber
p l epsilon is at least
one half v of omega epsilon p
okay and that's what we wanted
so just to recap
we have gotten
this
second bound here and therefore if we
want to calculate the bound on on this
guy we can take the match of these two i
mean really you could derive any number
of bounds that you want right
um and
and i guess what's interesting is that
these two bounds are often times for
many estimation problems enough to give
you a tight lower bound and we'll see
that in examples and just to um well
you'll see this also in the examples but
um at some level this uh this guy the
second bound is a population level
notion so it doesn't depend on the
sample size n or the dimensionality um
it will just depend on epsilon
um and
whereas this is the usual rate that we
would get in um in min max rates of
estimation like it might depend on p or
n or some problem parameters
and what we'll see is that oftentimes
you can just cleanly decompose the
optimal rate as let's say something like
root p over n max with epsilon so let's
see that in some examples so it makes
more sense
some of a question yeah i have a
question
um up there where you like distribute
the
cue into like two different terms
um
actually in that part like they
just needed a lower bound like superview
by the
mixture which puts like one half
probability on
like the q1 and the q2 constructed
so you're asking if that would be enough
to prove dilemma
i i just like i'm not sure uh you could
just distribute the suit q into the two
terms
directly
um
you mean right here
uh a little bit up um
yeah
so so we have dilemma here right so is
there a question about the lemma or how
we apply it
uh sorry uh your screen was lagging a
bit underneath the level yeah so so we
assume that the lemma is true right then
that gives us um that gives us a
distribution which is inside both balls
all right so at this calculation um
the very first inequality where you
write sub q is bigger than or equal to
and then two terms involving sub cube
mm-hmm
um
i think it's fine
i'm not sure i see where the question is
yeah i mean it it looks fine to me but i
guess i'll take a second look at it
before i release my notes and correct it
if necessary
all right
okay um
so i guess i'll keep going um
okay so
we let's go over um the first example
so what examples are we going to do
we're going to do two examples
um the first one is going to be gaussian
mean estimation or i guess earlier i
called it normal mean estimation
and the second one is going to be normal
covariance estimation
so these are the two examples that we
went through
earlier
so
uh so the first one is normal mean
estimation
and remember that in this case we had
xi's which were iid
normal theta sigma squared i
um and the the result well so theta was
going to be in rp
and from last time from lecture one
we have r sub
basically the usual min max rate
is equal to
the usual min max rate we were looking
in squared l2 norm
and this was omega of sigma squared p
over n
okay
um so our
our theorem says that we can also
calculate the modulus of continuity
and take the max of both so we will show
that the modulus of continuity
with respect
to l2 norm
is
omega of sigma epsilon
okay then
we'll get the bound of r uber
p
two norm squared epsilon
is going to be omega of
the max of
sigma squared p over n
and
sigma squared epsilon squared
okay so um just to remind you well the
bound that we have is um just
conveniently right here so it's order of
v of omega over two
and
i'm saying that we're going to show that
omega is
little omega is big omega of
sigma epsilon phi is the squared
is the squared function since we're
looking at l2 squared so we have to
square the sigma epsilon which is where
we get sigma squared epsilon squared
okay so you see that here this is where
i said that you get some rate that
depends on
on the sample size and dimensionality
and then some other rate it just depends
on epsilon
and
and this rate is achievable
using what's known as turkey's median
and again i'm not going to prove that
this actually works but
tukey's median is defined as the arg
soup
over theta in r to the p
um
femum over
unit vectors
1 over n sum i goes from 1 to n
indicator u transpose x i minus theta is
bigger than or equal to 0.
okay so let me just give you a pictorial
um illustration of what this is so
turkey's median
is a point that maximizes the data depth
so you can think about
this guy as the
data depth
and just as a picture so if you're
trying to figure out
what the
data depth of
let's say
this point is then the depth is measured
in terms of
looking at a half plane
and counting um how many points happen
to be um
sort of on one side of it so that's
that's where you get this in fema over
all directions you could project in this
is the the data depth um then then we
take a supremum over all the depths of
all the points and hopefully that gives
us some point that's kind of in the
middle okay so um so it turns out that
that this rate is indeed achieved by an
estimator which is
okay
so
and and maybe just interpret this rate
well it tells us that really um
depending on the level of contamination
we either get the usual rate or we or we
get something that just depends on
epsilon so if we had infinitely much
data then the first term would go down
to zero and the rate that we would get
would just depend on epsilon um
otherwise it says if epsilon is is
smaller than
epsilon is smaller than root p over n
then it says if the contamination wasn't
there
okay so
the point of this example is to show how
you would actually go about computing
so
so we write
omega
epsilon
p
is equal to the supremum
theta one minus theta two
the two norm is
uh such that total variation distance
between the two distributions
is bounded by epsilon over one minus
epsilon so this is just the definition
remember modulus of continuity is in
terms of the metric row and rho was
equal to the l2 norm
um
so it turns out so remember this is a
gaussian family and we're dealing with
total variation distances
and we have explicit formulas for kl
divergences between distributions so
we can use pinsker's inequality
to write this as
theta 1 minus theta 2
such that square root of one half
d k l
p theta one
e theta two
is less than or equal to epsilon over
one minus epsilon this is by pin squares
inequality
okay
um and this is now greater than or equal
to
so
we had a formula earlier for the kl
divergence between distributions
sorry between gaussian distributions
and
you can explicitly write this down
so you get supremum
theta 1 minus theta 2.
um
such that theta one minus theta two
two norm squared is less than or equal
to
four delta squared x one squared okay so
i think what happened here was
um i use the formula for the kl
divergence between two distributions
with mean theta one and theta two and
from this you have theta one minus h two
two norm squared as well as a factor of
um sigma squared and the only reason why
this is an inequality instead of
inequality is that i think that got rid
of the one minus epsilon term because i
didn't want that
um
so then this is of course equal to two
sigma times epsilon
right and that's the rate we wanted so i
claimed that um we had the modulus of
continuity lower bounded by order of
sigma epsilon so we're done
okay
um
so now let's do another example
so again we see that um
just to reiterate well what did how did
we get the the the final lower bound
which ended up being tight we got the
lower bound by just taking the lower
bound we would get from the usual um
method for minimax lower bounds and in
fact it doesn't have to come from fano
but in the first part of the talk we
derived the sound from final
and then we just need to calculate the
modulus of continuity to get the second
term
okay so
second example is
covariance matrix estimation
and for this example we take remember x
i is distributed
iid as normal zero sigma
um and what we had was that from last
time
ours of uber
i should say
so from lecture one
we have
ours of uber
of
script p
oh sorry um let me remind you that the
um the set
that sigma lived in was that we had um
well i'll just write it here so
the two norm of
sigma was founded by lambda
so
we have the
uncontaminated
risk in spectrum squared is equal to
omega of
lambda squared p over n that's what we
had last time
and now
we will show
that
the modulus of continuity
with respect
to the spectral norm
is
omega of lambda epsilon
then we have the lower bound
r sub uber
p
two norms squared epsilon
is equal to omega of lambda squared p
over n um
max with
lambda squared epsilon squared
okay
um
and this is again because um squared uh
spectral norm means that the fee
function is the square function so we
need to square this guy
um one other thing i forgot to mention
is that in both of these examples we're
showing that the modulus of continuity
is omega of lambda epsilon so you know
we could try to calculate the modulus of
continuity exactly that would be another
problem to solve but really in order to
get a lower bound we just need to
calculate a lower bound on modulus of
continuity and then of course to show
that this bound is tight then you would
need to do your analysis of the
algorithm that you claim achieves it and
um and because there exists an algorithm
which achieves it then that means that
it's actually typed
okay um so how do we
go about doing this calculation oh also
this is achievable
so this bound is achievable
using a generalization
of the 2k median
known as or based on matrix step
okay so in the case of um of the usual
turkey median you're looking at um at
projections of the data in
in in one dimension
right and when you're in in the space of
matrices you need to do something a
little bit different but you calculate
some notion of data depth for every
matrix and then you take the deepest
matrix
and this is all in the paper by chow gao
and co-authors um
okay so how do we calculate modules of
continuity so
consider
the matrices
sigma 1 equals lambda 2 lambda over 2
of the identity
and sigma 2
equals lambda over 2
identity plus b
epsilon times e
where
this guy is just a matrix with one entry
that's non-zero
okay
um
then we can check
that well first of all i won't even
write this down so you can check that
both um both of these guys are in the
the class of matrices is scheduled
unbounded by lambda namely um epsilon is
the level of contamination so the
spectral norm of this matrix is bounded
by two and therefore the overall
spectral number is bounded by lambda um
but furthermore you can check that there
is
an upper bound on the kl divergence
so we can check
using
the kl divergence
formula for gaussians
that
dkl of
p
sigma 1
p sigma 2
is bounded by epsilon squared over 4.
this is very easy to do actually because
these guys end up i mean if you have a
normal distribution with this covariance
and that covariance then the components
are independent so you can really just
ignore
all the remaining p minus one
coordinates and just look at the kl
between the first two um but in any case
so let's take this to be given so then
again using pin squares inequality
which um upper bounds the tv distance by
the kl then by the kl divergence we have
tv of
p sigma 1
p sigma 2 is bounded by square root of
one half times epsilon squared over four
which is bounded by one over epsilon
minus epsilon okay so therefore
the modulus of continuity is going to be
at least
the distance between these two guys
right and why is this well remember the
modulus of continuity is the soup over
row between the two parameters rho here
is a spectral norm of any pair of um
pair of matrices such that the tv
distance is bounded by absolute number
one minus epsilon
so here we've chosen one particular
pair
and this is
because
the two matrices have such a simple form
um this is going to be exactly equal to
lambda epsilon over t
okay so so that's what we want we
claimed that we had a bound on the
modulus of continuity order of lambda
epsilon
okay great so that's the um
that's the gist of how you come up with
how you can create lower bounds for this
robust
risk
um so now i just want to say two more
things before i end
so these are kind of comments
oops
so
you might ask well what what's with the
hoover epsilon contamination and total
variation distance so what if you want
to deal with other forms of
contamination
and there's one that's very popular
these days adversarial contamination
okay so adversarial contamination
says that you have
x i which are drawn iid from some
distribution p
and then epsilon n are arbitrarily
corrupted
to form
the new data set which let's call x
prime
okay so the minimax risk
you might be interested in here is
enthemum over theta hat supremum over
p and p
expectation
x distributed as
p to the n
supremum over
x prime of
loss function of theta hat applied to x
prime
theta of p
okay so why does this all make sense
well i'm generating my data from this
this clean distribution p i've n iid
samples
um and then i want to know well now the
nav is a premium over x prime inside the
uh the expectation because the adversary
after the x's are generated the
adversary can perturb arbitrarily and
then i calculate the loss between the
estimator and the perturbed data and and
the true parameter that i care about
um
so
uh so the main remark i wanted to say is
that
the lower bounds
via
uber
epsilon contamination
by the wraps on contamination mechanism
apply here can be applied here
okay so um
actually a lower bound
can be written of the form r sub huber
of let's say script p same l
and let's call it epsilon over two
okay and um let me just kind of
argue this in words
so uh what we're doing when we calculate
this adversarial risk is we're saying
well i can choose the worst possible
adversarial mechanism and i'm saying
that if you use a hoover epsilon
contamination adversary where you draw
most of your data from the clean
distribution and epsilon over two
fractions from the contaminated
distribution then this is one possible
case of an adversary and the reason is
that with high probability if you have
um
uh
right so with high probability um the
is that right yeah okay well something
like this is correct um so so you can
simulate um
the
the the action of the of the hoover
contaminator using the
okay
the logic is kind of twisted in my head
but um
but the point is that you that is that
um one possible form of an adversary is
where where the where the hoover
adversary just acts by drawing um some
fraction of data from the queen
distribution and then some fraction i id
from from
from an arbitrary distribution
um
and
uh and for instance in the case of
gaussian mean estimation so
in gaussian mean estimation
the latter lower bound is also tight
okay so the point is that um the
adversary is in general um a stronger
form of contamination um so the lower
bound that you would get could be bigger
so even though this is available or
bound you could get a bigger lower bound
in principle
um and but you can argue that the same
estimator that achieves the lower bound
for um for uber contamination which is
the tuki median also achieves the bound
that you would get in this case um
meaning that that this method of
bounding is tight
um then the other form of contamination
that i wanted to touch on briefly
because this is something that i've
looked at a bit in my own work
is wasserstein contamination
okay so historically people have looked
at uber contamination um because uber
was one of the key people in robust
statistics but you might consider other
perturbations of a distribution
um so instead you can define
the wasserstein min and max risk as
r sub was
pl epsilon
is equal to the enthemum over theta hat
and now we're looking at a supremum
over
distributions
w of p p prime less than or equal to
epsilon
um and now we draw data x from p prime n
l of theta hat of x
theta of p
okay so here um this is saying that
rather than the huber epsilon
contamination ball we're drawing from
some distribution p prime which is in
the wasserstein ball um here w
denotes
the wasserstein distance and in the
particular
case i want to mention
um let's say it's the losses sign one
distance
which can be written in terms of
losses sign distance between
p1 and p2 is the supremum
over all
one lipschitz functions of
expectation
under x coming from p1 of f of x
minus expectation x coming from p2
f of x
okay
and then we can define the modulus of
continuity
and now we'll call it
omega w loss of
epsilon p
and this is equal to the supremum and
now it's going to look very similar to
what we had earlier
except of course there's no total
variation distance anymore so we have
theta p1 theta p2
such that the washer sine distance
between p1 and p2 is less than or equal
to epsilon
okay so this is saying um how close do
the does um do the two parameters look
for distributions which are now close in
boston's sign distance and remember
earlier we had total variation distance
because that was directly related to the
hoover ball
so one can derive
so we can derive
the lower bound
r sub was
p l epsilon is greater than or equal to
the max
of r sub plus
p l zero so here's the same thing where
there's no contamination
and then the second term is one half v
of
omega sub y of
epsilon p
over 2.
okay so at least in terms of the syntax
this looks exactly the same as before
right we have one half phi of the
modulus of continuity over two
so really where what's special why why
am i stating this specifically for a
wasserstein one distance um
well if you remember the way that the
proof went for the uber epsilon
contamination ball i needed um so the
proof
before and here as well needed
that
if p1 and p2
optimize
the modulus of continuity problem
program which is this program up here
then there exists a distribution
um in both
epsilon balls okay so here we are
looking in terms of waster sign up some
contamination ball and it turns out that
um in this case it's very simple
actually um here
for wasserstein distance p prime equals
one half p1 plus one half p2 actually
works the mixture just works
then this comes from um this duality
form of wasserstein distance and you can
just plug in what happens when you when
you look at a mixture
okay
and actually the same sort of argument
would say that if we cared about
so you can think about um a version of
of contamination where this is replaced
by total variation distance um instead
of hoover ball and and i think the same
argument would work where this is the tv
ball and this is now tv so you can play
around with several different metrics
um and
and maybe the the last thing is that um
for
gaussian
mean and covariance estimation with
washer sign contamination
then you can actually show that the
um
the modulus of continuity is of the same
order as in the tb case
that omega
wasserstein epsilon p is of the same
order as omega uh omega uber
so here this guy was the hoover
uber modulus
of continuity from before
okay so the same um bounds on the
um
on the
on the
contaminated robust risk hold
and perhaps more interesting
interestingly and the lower bounds are
also tight
can also be achieved
and in my own work i've showed that this
can be achieved using a notion of a
wasserstein gan
okay so i'll end here and i'm happy to
take any questions on this lecture
see a question out there
i own great tutorials i was wondering if
you could comment a bit uh about the
computational complexity of computing
the duke medium
oh really i don't know off the top of my
head but
you know i think it's like n to the p
but um it is computationally intractable
and uh are there
computationally efficient estimators
that you know get
something close or
or yeah
so
um
so i mentioned very briefly uh like the
last sentence i said was that i had um
i had done some work where uh where i
found computationally well
where where i studied the wasserstein
contamination model using wasserstein
gans um so this was very much inspired
by work by chao gao a few years ago
where he used
total variation versions of
of gans in order to try to simulate what
the 2k media is doing
so you could use something like that as
you are
as a computational tool and if if such a
method um
is is able to actually find an optimum
then then that will
also
give you a computationally retractable
version of the two median
um
there are some results too on um
let's see i guess if your data are
i i i don't feel qualified to say this
off the top of my head because i'm
almost definitely gonna say something
wrong um but there are also various
results um where rare data come from
nice distributions um where you can get
some sort of um some other estimators
that also perform well
and i'm pretty sure at least one person
in the audience has probably worked on
this problem
in the worst case could there be some
kind of uh information competition gaps
here or
yeah i mean
um if your data are not coming from some
molds distribution like are you if
you're just talking about computing
computing the tukey median for sure
what about the robust mean estimation
problem
yeah um
it's possible um i i don't know off the
top of my head
it does
rust sparsely distribution so without
without sparse the
story is different
yeah i guess the short answer is it's
complicated but robust first
great thanks
more questions
um can i have something from the zoom
yeah
uh thank you very much for the though um
so one question i had is like
is there like these results seem to be
applying for like input distributions
which are like products right so kind of
product like
what if like uh
what if like for example the inputs like
a graph or like you know that has some
graph structure like other is there like
some mechanisms to produce lower bounds
for past estimators
yeah well i guess what i would say there
is that the in the first structure the
bounds for final were stated in a very
general form um i don't know off the top
of my head of examples in which
lower bounds and matching upper bounds
have been studied when you don't have id
data but in principle yes you could use
the bounds from the very first part in
much more generality
but for the robust part
oh for the robust part um
i don't know off the top of my head
more questions from the from the live or
zoom audience
okay all right in that case i guess
we'll wrap it up thank you so much
pulling for the great tutorials
um
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks
and we'll resume it to p.m